So we talked to Rich Fulcher, a design-minded
developer on the Android team at Google. So
he's going to tell us a little bit about
personas and use cases, and basically blow our minds.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Hi, I'm Rich Fulcher. I started my career with a
Master's degree in Computer Science and was programming computer graphics for
quite a while. But then I switched over and I became
a designer. And now I'm a designer and manager as part
of the Android team here at Google. I think there's a
huge temptation at the start of a project to just kind of
get going and do the thing you want to do the most. You
know, when you're a designer, you want to start drawing. When you're a
developer you want to start building out those APIs, or start coding, or
kind of get to that first screen. But you want to temper
that, you can do that and it's okay to engage with that
kind of passion you have for what you do, but you also
want to make sure that you're, you're building in the right
direction, the only way you can do that is to be aware
of the users. So you need to start thinking, you know, who
is this audience that I'm building this thing for? It can't just
be me, it's gotta be much bigger than that. So, how can
I understand them, how can I make sure that the things I'm
excited about, these use cases that I'm thinking about, really line up
with what their goals, and what the needs of the user are?
So, one way that you can think about users
is through the use of a persona. You know, just
trying to build out your model of how this
person other than yourself, you know, one of your users
just more information about them and kind of what their goals
and what their contexts of use are. When you have those
personas the next step is to really think about well, how
do they act with your product? And one way you capture
that, them completing a task, is through a use case. You
know, what are the steps they go through to complete a
specific sub-goal? So you have your personas, and you have your
use cases. How do they influence the way you treat development?
Well, something I do is I try to refer to
those personas by name whenever I can. Or I try
to talk to the specific use cases. And if I'm
talking just about myself and my opinions, I'll make a
distinction by just repeating the word I. I'll say, well,
I, I, I think this. To make a clear kind
of gulf between what I personally think, and what I
as a designer representing these personas, think should be true.